I've made this warm Chimichurri
chicken and orzo salad
probably twice a week for the last month or so
and in my opinion it's getting pretty close to perfection
and it's not just quick easy and delicious
but it's adaptable to whatever season you're in
or whatever protein you'd like
and somehow the leftovers taste even better the next day
start by finding dicing garlic
half a shallot alongside coriander and parsley
pop all that in a large mixing bowl and then add dried oregano
red wine vinegar olive oil
lemon juice and salt and pepper
give it a stir then
I like to reserve about half a cup at this point
and like anything the longer you marinate it for
the better it tastes
so you can make the chimichurri sauce
or marinate the chicken ahead of time
but today I'm in a rush so I've added seared chicken
transferred that to a cast iron dish
and pop that in the oven at about 200°C for about half an hour
for my salad I've got orzo, chickpeas
rocket tomato cucumber
capsicum avocado and bocconcini
pour over the reserved dressing and then give it a good mix
and then to plate I put a generous portion of that salad down
top it with my sliced chimichurri chicken
and I finish it all off with some extra sauce from the pan
and I'm telling you right now
this meal will not disappoint
each bite is a flavour experience
it's herby, it's tangy
it's hearty and dare I say it
fkn good for you